in any textbook overview of hinduism you
will quickly encounter the caste system
and the caste system is this notion that
people are born into the roles that they
have to play in society
now the reason why i put this in quotes
is because they are associated with this
notion from the various hindu scripture
of varnas but the best translation from
sanskrit into english of varnas is
classes
and it's interesting to think about
whether they were first intended to be
just social classes or also hereditary
classes as the caste system implies what
we do know is that as we approach modern
hinduism over the last several hundred
years it did approach something that was
more what you are born into but we'll
look at a little bit at the scripture
and i'll leave it up to you to decide
whether it was more of a social class or
it was a class that you are born into
now the four varnas that are described
in the vedas and in other hindu
scripture at the top you have the
brahmins who are the priests and the
teachers not to be confused with the god
brahma or the ultimate reality brahman
next you have the kashatriyas who are
the warriors and rulers and it's
interesting that at least in hindu
society the brahmanas were considered
higher than the warriors the rulers the
kings
after that you have the vaisyas who are
the farmers the merchants and then next
the shudras the laborers those who
worked in service to the other three
classes
now you also had and have people who are
outside of these four different classes
today they refer to themselves as dalits
which means the oppressed but sometimes
they've been referred to as untouchable
and that's because in traditional
hindu society many of these people
weren't even able to enter temples they
were discriminated against they weren't
had they didn't have access to resources
they weren't even allowed to shake hands
or make physical contact with other
members of hindu society and we'll talk
a little bit more about how this may or
may not be changing
now to see the basis of the varna system
in scripture i will start with this
quote from the rigveda now this is from
the purusha sukta and purusha and the
vedas you can view as this
cosmic being but they anthropomorphize
this being making it seem or making it
analogy with a human body
when they divided the cosmic being how
many portions did they make
what do they call his mouth his arms
what do they call his thighs and feet
the brahman was his mouth
of both arms was the rajanya maid the
regina you could view as the kashatriyas
the warriors and the kings his thighs
became the vaisya from his feet the
sudra was produced
so in the vedas and there's some dispute
about whether this was originally in the
vedas or about whether it was added
later to have a creation story
but it is making reference to these four
varnas
but here it is not 100 clear whether
it's just talking about the various
classes of society they're bound to have
some priests and teachers some wars and
rulers some farmers merchants some
laborers or are they saying something
more fundamental
now we can go to the time of the
mahabharat when the mahabharat was
written
and the subset of the mahabharata which
is the bhagavad-gita and they also make
reference to this varna system so the
bhagavad-gita is the part of the
mahabharata where you have krishna
talking to arjun and reassuring him
about his role in life
and this is what krishna tells arjun a
brahmana's virtues born of his nature
are serenity self-control austerity
purity tolerance honesty learning and to
know the truth of things which be
a kashatri is pride born of his nature
lives in valor exuberance determination
resourcefulness bravery and battle and
generosity and noble demeanor as a lord
of men a vicious task born with his
nature is to till the ground tend cattle
venture trade
a sudra state suiting his nature is
service arguably in service to the other
three classes
now once again it doesn't make
strict reference to you are born a
brahmana if your father was a brahmana
then you have to be a brahmana or if
your father was a kashatriya you will be
a kashatriya it is making reference to
this idea of being
born
of his nature
so you could interpret that is it this
is this idea that you have some innate
gifts you have some innate tendencies
and those innate tendencies are going to
dictate whether you're going to be a
brahmana a kashatriya of aisha or sudra
i encourage you as always to look up the
primary documents yourself and
especially when you're looking at
something that is a translation this is
a translation from sanskrit to english
how it is translated matters so try to
look up multiple translations and come
to your own conclusion
now regardless of whether the
ancient hindu scripture the
bhagavad-gita is over 2000 years old if
we're talking about the vedas and if
especially if that especially if the
purusha
was part of the original vedas we're
talking about something that's over 3000
years old regardless of the original
intent of the varna system whether it
was supposed to be just talking about
classes as opposed to a hereditary cast
the reality is is over the last several
hundred years in india it did become a
cast people whose parents were brahmanas
became brahmanas people whose parents
were kashatriyas became kashatriyas and
they married amongst themselves and it
did dictate their social status
and so to put all of this in perspective
i'm going to give you a quote from
really one of india's founding fathers
so this is a picture of br ambedkar and
he was born a dalit and faced
significant discrimination when he was
growing up he wasn't allowed to sit on
chairs or eat next to his fellow
students
as you can imagine his family wouldn't
have had access to nowhere near the
resources that other people in a village
or in a city would have had access to
they would have been actively
discriminated with
they wouldn't have been able to even
make physical contact with members of
the formal varna system but despite all
of that discrimination he was able to
get a significant education and
eventually become india's first law
minister and not only that but the
principal architect of the indian
constitution
and this is what he wrote about the
caste system cast is not a physical
object like a wall of bricks or a line
of barbed wire which prevents the hindus
from commingling and which has therefore
to be pulled down caste is a notion it
is a state of the mind
and if you look at modern india or if
you talk to modern hindus
many of them will say hey we don't take
cast seriously we view this as a part of
our past and a part of our past that
we're not necessarily that proud of
but there are still hindus who do take
the caste system seriously especially if
you go into rural areas and villages
many of the things that br ambedkar
faced this level of discrimination of
dalits not being able to go to a temple
not having access to water resources
this is still happening in india and in
things like inter-marriage the caste
system is still taken reasonably
seriously by a large portion of the
hindu population
now here's another quote from br
ambedkar
some men say that they should be
satisfied with the abolition of
untouchability only leaving the caste
system alone
the aim of abolition of untouchability
alone without trying to abolish the
inequalities inherent in the caste
system is a rather low aim